so the heading is calculus with other
bases John I'm speaking you should be
listening thank you so let's make a
start gonna jump right in when you hear
the phrase are the bases what you should
be thinking is well when is in calculus
when is it important to have a specific
base and then there are like the other
bases have a think bases what does that
indicate to you what what words come to
your mind when you hear that yet
logarithms what else exponential is very
good so in both Exponential's and
logarithms there's one particular base
that is the most important to us we
caught the natural base it is a 2.718
etc right this base a that we know is
about 2.7 is super important it makes
all of the calculus go super nice right
but of course we don't always have that
base we sometimes have two or ten or
whatever number you like right so how do
we do with the calculus with this let me
remind you of how we differentiate when
we differentiate something like say two
to the power of X now if you think back
to when we did this the first time the
exponential curve it does look like this
right
every exponential curve looks something
like that so the derivatives of these
exponential curves are also exponential
curves do you remember that right so of
course the classic example is e to the X
the derivative of e to the X is of
course just e to the X right but when we
have to give these guys this a slight
adjustment we have to make you do get 2
to the X like that same exponential with
this base that you started with but then
we have to adjust it because only e to
the X that's the only one that lands
back exactly on itself does anyone
remember what the adjustment is we have
to multiply by something takers I'll
give you a clue it starts with an L it's
gonna be a log what kind of log Ln it'll
be the natural log and then the natural
log of whatever base you got given so if
we'd started with 5 to the X it would
have been log 5 I'll go to there so it's
going to be log
- okay that's the derivative . that's it
okay we can of course generalize this
it's not just true for - it's true for
any number or constant I should say a so
if a was a million or negative three
whatever you like right
negatory is actually not a good example
for other reasons when you put this in
you're gonna get the original
exponential and then finish finish it
off what do you do log of hey thank you
which one - in our first instance there
okay now this was in differential
calculus land where I enter your
calculus land now right so I'm
interested in what happens when we
integrate such results now thankfully
this result here paves the way for us
because we know integration is the
opposite of differentiation so if I
integrate this guy instead of
differentiating a to the X DX
just like differentiating an exponential
gives you a different exponential well
integrating an exponential will give you
a different exponential it's gonna look
or start off looking much the same when
we differentiate it we we when we
differentiate it we multiplied by log a
so this time we're going to divide by
log n that'll undo the differentiation
you saw before not to forget this is of
course an integral so the last thing we
need is our constant of integration plus
C and we're done
okay